I do want to get on the record you one
of my absolute favorite oh you're so
you're so great you're a killer kinda
don't believe you but then I wouldn't
know Oh cuz you saw ya know usually
compliment me I've seen you for almost a
decade now back at comics remember comic
oh yeah New York bankrupt did it will
you shut it down
they were like you can't get me better
are you still get up a lot in town um
yeah I like to go up at certain places
in town I never see you anymore yeah I
do the Comedy Store oh I was raised I
was recently dissed at the Comedy Store
dissed and dismissed well it was um are
you familiar with the comedy of Martin
Lawrence yeah he's seen him has anyone
seen Martin Lawrence do comedy lately
I haven't seen him do it lately well
he's at the call he was at The Comedy
Store that Joe goes up he goes up but
like at the Comedy Store there's no host
so you have to like introduce each other
so Martin Lawrence is like killing it's
Friday night and this guy is like a
master at [ __ ] jokes like I don't know
you have red [ __ ] white [ __ ] deep
[ __ ] mossy [ __ ] plaid [ __ ] like he
cut it was like in Forrest Gump when
they talk about the shrimp
this guy talked about so he's sweaty
we're just gonna let that slip on mine I
saw it immediately swag was it yep
so Martin's killing and then he's like
okay who's next and they're like Natasha
Leggero from the side and he's like who
and they're like Natasha Leggero he's
like who and they say it one more time
he's like I'm black I can't say that
[ __ ] first of all if I said I couldn't
say someone's name cuz I'm white
I wouldn't be able to leave my house for
six years so that's how long you have to
wait it out so then I get up on stage oh
no this is what he goes he goes he goes
so finally I go to the back he can't say
my name so I'm like Martin just say
Natasha and he goes [ __ ] I don't work
for you
yeah the point I was just trying to make
it easy and like this is Martin I mean I
was intimidated our TV shows like
Martin's stars of movies like Big
Momma's House Big Momma's House - Big
Momma's House 2 talking dirty after dark
oh is that one of us yeah it opens with
him yeah
the first shot of that movie is he wakes
up with an erection and he thrusts it
into the camera and that's what I was
like we made the right choice I was
about 12 some of you are interpreting
that so many different ways so talking
dirty so I get up on stage and then I
have like pretty bad set I just want to
leave after my show I felt really bad
you address it when you went out not he
like got a standing ovation like they
loved him and it was just what it's okay
so then well it gets weirder so I want
to just leave I go out to the parking
lot and he's waiting for me in the
parking lots what's still sweating from
his day he killed so hard and he came he
pulled me over he goes Natasha I don't
work for you he's still mad about it I
mean I I forgave him I mean that well
that's that's that's the night we
discover I had him I have a plaid [ __ ]
he's sweating like I'm like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't work for you
no we made up eventually and he was
sweet I told him to hold my purse and
then he laughed I'll tell you what you
should have done if he had a coffee or
something give him the money just been
like you work for me then send them a
1099 yeah the racial implications of
this story it's difficult stiff with all
the lip on it be racial he was rude no
I'm just listening to the audience I'm
like they're like is that a race Chuck
you know what it means to me it's just
like you couldn't tell an audience
to release the pheromones that they
release when race things are happening
but this audience is killing it I like
this audience oh no this is the best
audience I think we've ever had I talked
to the gal everybody